le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
365 jours pour agir 7 jours pour le dire
c'est le slogan de la semaine bleue cet
événement national le chaque année les
retraités et les personnes âgées en
l'honneur sur l'île
c'est l'occasion pour les ehpad
d'organiser spectacles et ateliers tout
au long de la semaine à saint louis
des lycéens ont coopéré avec leurs aînés
pour donner vie à une pièce de théâtre
intergénérationnel
[Musique]
ce avant les savons où il y avait le
savons il n'a fallu que quelques minutes
pour transformer cette cafétéria en loge
de théâtre
allez on y va en place à saint louis
l'effervescence de cette classe de lycée
vient animer la matinée de cet
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées
ces étudiants sont en formation services
de proximité et de vie locale à
l'occasion de la semaine bleue
ils ont préparé une pièce de théâtre en
l'honneur des personnes âgées
ce matin ils sont en pleine répétition
générale il s'agit d'une rencontre
intergénérationnelle où là nous avons
donc mis en place en fait une activité
théâtre pour cette année il s'agit de
faire une présentation sur le thème bal
la poussière tandis qu'à repartir en
fait dans les années 60 sur l'histoire
de la réunion le bal la poussière
repartir sur des scènes authentique avec
la boîte de l'an postic retrouver des
objets lontan et aussi être vraiment
dans le langage du créole longtemps
qu'on utilisait type hawaïen à fait là
se voit trouve à zéro point l'histoire
raconte comment gertrude avec la
complicité de sa soeur veut se rendre
aux bals du samedi pour y retrouver si
angelo un garçon qui lui a tapé dans
l'oeil
pour recréer l'ambiance de l'époque
les élèves se sont inspirés des récits
et des souvenirs des résidents de
l'ehpad
on a une idée du ballon longtemps on est
venu à l'ehpad on leur impose éducation
sur le passé comment c'était d'un
mariage etc
pour en savoir plus pour justement bien
jouer la scène changé il dit avoir a
cappella qu'elle y est
mariën a participé à l'élaboration du
projet l'occasion pour la pensionnaire
de revivre ces jours de fête
non sans un brin de nostalgie dans
l'élite et journée mais qu'on est
d'aller faire appel à nous revoir
mais j'ai pu parler non pas au bal la
poussière bannu dans ce vraiment dans la
poussière
maman les soeurs et frères le tout
ensemble
alors après ses comptes dès demain alors
entré pour les jeunes acteurs c'est le
choc des générations à travers le récit
de leurs anciens ils ont découvert une
société aux normes bien différente de
celle d'aujourd'hui est stricte il
fallait que ne pas une autre mais
revenons à contacter les garçons ne
pouvait pas faire la bise au fil il
pouvait pas avoir un contact de pau
s'est pas vraiment comme aujourd'hui
donc c'est un petit peu bizarre bizarre
mais enrichissant
les étudiants ont été surpris par
certaines expressions créoles de
l'époque plus là et plus souffle où l on
sait qu'en dans le bail ces campagnes
sont souvent quand un garçon veut
inviter une fille à danser mais quand la
fia ne veux pas me later this light et
celles épluchées est de taille ce lien
entre les générations
c'est ce que tente de réaliser les
différents et pas de lille dans le cadre
de la semaine rue où nous étions en
valeur et une mettons en avant ses
gramoune et nous essayons de faire en
sorte que les nouvelles générations
voici g ce sont notre regard c'est très
important pour nous la terre
générationnel si nous sommes là
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à nos parents et
à ne croire nos grands parents parce que
ce sont les premiers éducateurs
alors nous devons à nos gramounes du
respect et nous devons les aînés dans 24
heures les élèves présenteront leur
spectacle à tous les pensionnaires et à
d'autres classes de jeunes le résultat
de plusieurs mois de coopération qui
devrait se conclure sur quelques pas de
danse
j'aimerais bien le voyage à écraser bas
[Musique]
la semaine bleue est un événement
national créé il y à 60 ans l'objectif
est de mettre à l'honneur les retraités
et les personnes âgées pendant sept
jours à la réunion les ehpad sont gérés
par le département la collectivité
propose gramoune plusieurs autres
dispositifs qui vise à améliorer leur
qualité de vie comme l'aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat où le
système des aidants familiaux
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.cnrs.fr
[Musique]